Have you on.
Welcome to toxic Google.
Thanks for much for joining us today.
It's my pleasure to welcome Sarah Robb O'hagan to the office to talk about her
new book,
extreme.
You step up,
stand out,
kick ass.
Repeat the book.
Not only inspires you to take risks and step out of the box,
but it's also funny,
entertaining and super interesting as she takes you through her own personal
journey of success and failure and how they have got her to where she is today.
Please join me in welcoming her.
Good morning Googlers.
How is everyone ready to rock it out?
All right,
so I generally like to,
um,
start my talks with just a little bit of context.
Where's the crazy accent from?
I am from New Zealand.
Does anyone ever been there in the room?
There's always one.
There's two.
Is it amazing?
It's kind of amazing.
So it is like,
it's,
it was discovered in 1769 actually by captain James Cook,
who wrote in his log book.
I believe I had found God zone.
I mean,
I'm not even kidding.
It's the most gorgeous place on the planet.
So why would I leave New Zealand's you wonder,
well there's like 4 million people and almost 50 million sheep.
Let's just start there.
That is not like a joke.
That is exactly what my country looks like.
So as a young person growing up,
you can imagine I had a lot of like,
well is this it like is this my people or is there more than the world?
Like how do we go beyond a New Zealand is also a country that is very passionate
about sports.
I loved that.
I'd got my crew team in the back row here today.
So like Americans were really into sport in America.
Well in New Zealand we're a little country but we like swing hard and the 1984
Olympics,
which most of you probably can't even remember because you weren't born.
I was like a 12 year old watching on TV as we got the most metals we've ever won
and our history and that was 12 medals you guys,
it's amazing.
Like twice.
Like we were number one on the global per capita metals table.
That's a big deal to us.
But what's really cool about it is every middle that we one involved a sport
where they were sitting down.
Isn't that amazing?
Look at the pictures.
Like literally cycling,
rowing,
Kayaking,
horse riding.
I could go on like we crushed it at the sports that involve,
who would've thought?
Right?
So why am I sharing this funny story with you is because I do believe as a young
person growing up,
it did leave quite a profound thought with me.
And that is that it takes extreme focus to achieve extraordinary results like
those little kiwis punching above their weight.
You have to really have focus on something that is your unique specialty.
And you'll see in the pictures here,
I've had the great pleasure of working for some of the world's most brands,
sustaining amazing brands.
And what they all have in common is this detailed,
detailed focus on what they are,
where they're going,
why they're unique,
and they don't get distracted.
As the years go by and it's,
it's specially important when the landscape is so rapidly changing.
And for me being someone who's gone,
everything from virgin mega stores,
does anyone even remember virgin mega stores when the music industry got
disrupted and that company no longer exists through to the likes of Nike,
which is driving innovation and pushing forward more than any other company in
the world.
The big difference is those that consistently play their own game,
but just stay in front and disrupt themselves before the industry does it to
them.
So I've had these great career experiences and the process of writing my book
led me to say,
well,
what does this actually mean for individuals as well and and leaders.
And you can see here I,
over the last three years it's been,
I have interviewed 25 of some of the most profoundly successful people on the
planet because I wanted to know just like those brands,
what is it about them that uniquely enables them to stay on the top of their
game?
And what I did is I went to great lengths to sort of go to all walks of life.
So you see some of the pictures here,
everyone from Condoleezza Rice who we all know who's like the world's most
amazing,
bad us through to Bodie Miller,
who's a downhill skier through to Mr Cartoon,
who's one of the world's most famous tattoo artists,
Sam Kass,
the White House chef.
What they all have in common is this incredible ability to know their own
specialties,
to know what they're amazing at,
to focus like those little kiwis and to constantly disrupt themselves whenever
they get to mastery,
push themselves to the next level.
So with that said,
I think about this framework that I've been developing and discovering,
and it starts with you,
the person,
like those individuals I just talked about.
What is extreme you?
What is you at your most optimum potential?
Like what is the core set of skills that you have?
And generally extremists,
as I call them,
are not well rounded.
They're not the kinds of people that have tons of experience and a lot of
places,
they're probably super good at one specialty and really passionate about it and
we love them.
And the workplace,
however they need to be partnered with complimentary people to become extreme
teams like when we get lots of complimentary skills together.
And then ultimately the extreme organization is that organization that is loaded
with people with incredible skills and specialist areas.
But together they come together and focus on a really,
really focused mission.
So with that said,
I'm going to go through three examples today of the kind of key tenants that I
learned from all these amazing businesses and all these amazing leaders in
developing the idea that was extreme year.
And the first one is what I like to call,
make failure your fuel.
It is possibly my most favorite topic in the world.
Um,
and it starts with the fact that I,
um,
had had a career,
mainly a in the sports and fitness industry.
If you googled me a couple of years ago,
what you would have seen is that I was known for turning around Gatorade,
a $5 billion sports drink business.
I had all these things like fast company's most creative people in business.
That looks amazing,
right?
But what it totally left out was the fact that in my twenties,
I got fired.
Not once,
but twice back to back.
And I like to share the story because I believe in our culture today of success,
whether it's lists of the 40 under 40,
30,
under 30,
20,
under 20,
whether it's perfectly quaffed Instagram pictures,
we tend to show all the amazing stuff and we don't tend to show some of the
really embarrassing,
not so cool stuff.
So one of the reasons I wrote this book was I felt it was important to share a,
particularly with young people that you have to fail in order to know who you
are and in order to succeed in the future.
My example of virgin,
like I mentioned,
was virgin mega stores.
I joined,
uh,
in the late nineties,
the year Napster had come along.
So let's just go there.
Remember that?
I still remember that,
like how big moment it was may and we had to like comp Ricky Martin's album
sales from the year before.
Like that's how awesome it was.
But in the end,
the company actually went under for all the reasons I said before because they
were being disrupted from outside and not taking care of themselves.
But my experience was someone who'd come in from a high flying role at Virgin
Atlantic Airways.
I thought I had it down.
I was like rocking and rolling,
not listening to anyone around me at a totally foreign business,
so over my skis.
So arrogant and I got fired.
Not like laid off one person hired.
And let me explain to you what that feels like.
When you go into the office and HR is sitting there and you feel a blood rush
out or your face and you get told that you have a one week severance,
they're getting rid of your green card application on your visa and you get a
one way ticket back to New Zealand.
In other words,
we don't want you in our company,
we don't even want you in our country.
Like that's how awesome it was.
So I go through that and then desperate times call for desperate measures.
I have three months to stay in the country and I ended up taking a job at Atari.
Does anyone have this room?
Remember Tyrese and fond fans?
I would imagine,
which was a disaster for me because I completely overlooked the fact that I
cannot stand video games,
never have liked them,
have no interest in them,
don't understand them.
Within two years,
that's another company in distress and a bunch of people are getting laid off in
a course.
I'm one of them.
So by this stage,
I'm now in my late twenties I've had up to four years of epic Korea failure,
right?
Disastrous.
Like I call it fondly my canyon of Korea despair.
It was terrible.
But here's the thing,
that same person that was a total flame out and these two environments,
eventually after I leave Atari,
I'm desperately trying to find the right role for me going forward.
I finally land at Nike after 12 months of interviewing and trying and getting in
the door,
and that same loser girl suddenly becomes on the fast track,
having a great career rocking and rolling.
Right.
And the lesson here for me was you have to experience extreme environments to
understand where you suck and where you thrive.
And when you get yourself onto the playing field where you thrive,
it feels amazing and you know,
the difference in all your confidence comes back.
And that is the importance of failure on the way to success.
Because quite honestly,
had I not just come through those two back to back firings,
I don't think I would've had the humility coming in the door to succeed at Nike.
I mean,
literally I walk in the door and I'm like,
please don't fire me.
Please don't fire me.
I will do anything to do well here.
And one of the great athletes that I had the pleasure of working with when I was
at Nike was Bodie Miller.
Do you guys know Bodie?
He's awesome by the way.
I mean the best skier in the world to watch because there is nothing between,
uh,
like disqualified and goals.
Like that's just the way he rolls.
But I,
uh,
really got to know him around the 2006 Torino Olympics.
And he's extraordinary when you talk to him about failure because he talked
about as a child when he was learning to ski in New Hampshire,
he physically was smaller than the other skiers.
So he kept coming in like 30th 40th like certainly not podium potential.
Right.
And the trainers kept saying to all of them,
we've just got to kind of push yourself incrementally.
That was the way they were training scares in those those days.
And he's like,
well that ain't working for me clearly.
So finally he's like,
I got to go my own way and figure this out.
And he starts skiing and practice like balls to the wall.
If anyone's watched the sky ski,
there was no like holding back and he would crash a lot and it was painful.
But as he said,
that was pushing him to the edge of his own boundaries is edge of his comfort
level and teaching him to be able to eventually recover and those crashes to get
to the next level.
So on race day when the other guy suddenly go full steam ahead,
they're crashing.
He actually now can push to a higher level because he's taught himself through
the very act of crashing and failing and pain to get to the next level.
So a great metaphor for all of us as we think about our own careers.
All right,
so that's making failure.
Your fuel number two I like to talk about is playing.
You'll specialist game.
What does that mean for you personally?
So I came upon this idea from studying these great brands and businesses that
I've been lucky enough to be involved with.
And I'll pick out a few here just to share with you.
So Virgin Atlantic Airways,
is anyone flown virgin?
Is that not awesome?
You get your hair done at the club house.
It's amazing.
But Virgin,
super interesting to me because having spent about eight years in the airline
industry,
most of you would know if you fly United or American,
especially this week.
Uh,
but their target audience is generally human beings with arms and legs,
right?
You know what I'm saying?
Whereas Virgin when they came into the business,
they're like,
we're not going after everyone.
We're going to have this really defined position and we're going to focus on
people who are into culture and technology and entertainment and fashion.
Everything was built around that positioning.
And as a result they built this incredible position as an airline.
Like they think of the travel experience,
I think more as entertainment than travel.
I mean they even got to the point where they were able to sort of be an arbiter
of great taste of movies and flight because they thought about it that way.
Likewise,
Strava,
do I have any Strava users in the room?
Can't believe that we've got to get you out onto your bike's guys.
Strivers the social network for athletes that um,
they're based out in silicon valley and what they do is obviously track runners,
cycling,
all you sort of fitness activities.
But as the founder said to me when I interviewed them for my book,
like at the time they were born,
the fitbit market was what everyone was going after cause it's big and as
massive and they are like,
well we could have done that but then we would have been number 10 and a giant
market instead of they just went off to cyclists and only cyclists and they were
number one for this really small group.
And from there they've managed to push out because they're going after very,
very passionate athletes.
And then lastly,
the dry bar ladies in this room nodding.
The guys right now are going,
WTF,
what is driver?
They are,
I could tell drive our is an extraordinary story.
I love it.
I interviewed alley,
the founder for,
for my book basically for many years hairdressing was certainly on the women's
side.
You go to a hairdresser and anything you want to get done,
you get done.
So cuts,
colors,
get your hair blown out.
Any of the above.
Well Allie,
who founded the dry by was like,
I really don't want to do all of that stuff.
I'm just really good at blowing out here because I've loved doing it since I was
a child and I want to create an entire concept just around that one thing.
Now most people would say,
how the hell are you going to build a business right around that one thing when
women need all these other things done from a beauty standpoint as well,
but she's like,
I'm going to be better than anyone at doing this one thing.
Sure enough,
Drybar is now coming close to 100 million top line business based on the fact
that she's created an entire category out of this one thing because women,
we didn't used to rock along and spend five bucks for a blowout once or twice a
week because the category didn't exist.
She's now created it and as many obviously people following her and she gets so
many people saying,
well,
why don't you add,
you know,
makeup or nails or all the other things that women would want.
And she's like,
because that would take away my focus from what I'm really,
really good at and I want to be the best at this one thing.
And it's such a great lesson because when you take all of those brands lessons
and then think about yourself as an individual,
how do you think about yourself being positioned like a brand would be?
How do you think about your career in terms of imagining that you are that
product in the marketplace that you're trying to attract people to come by?
Do you feel just like those three examples that you are super uniquely
differentiated?
Do you feel like the airline example that you're just trying to be all things to
all people or do you have your one unique thing?
Do you feel like Allie,
that you have that specialty that you really are better at than anyone else?
Because I do believe when you have that and you become super world class,
that is propels your career forward.
So in my example,
I actually spent most of my life being really,
really,
really average.
So I'm talking really wanted to be a world class Olympic medal winning athlete.
Never made the a team in any sport that I participated in at all.
Really wanted to be a world famous singer.
I actress never got picked for Solos.
Actually,
when we did grease at my high school,
I didn't even make the pink ladies.
I was that section that doesn't go on the stage,
you know,
clearly just not cut out to be really amazing and any of those things.
However,
who would have thought?
I didn't know 1520 years later when I finally had gone through all these trials
and tribulations that what I actually was developing was this incredibly
competitive mindset on probably the most competitive human being in the room
right now,
combined with a very creative brain,
developed through tons and tons of music combined with years of adventuring and
the travel industry,
which all comes together to make me uniquely good at innovation and the sports
and fitness industry.
Who would have thought?
I didn't even know that was a Korea,
but when I pulled those things together,
that's where I suddenly found,
wait,
I'm not getting fired anymore.
I've done it all together and it's interesting for all of you to understand what
is that for you?
Because when you find it,
when you know it,
when opportunity knocks,
boy you have to knock down the door.
And in my case I uh,
actually about six months ago was not working,
not looking for a job cause I was working on the launch of this book.
And along comes an opportunity with flywheel sports and I don't know if you guys
are familiar with it,
I'll quickly tell you a little but about flywheel.
But it's unique because it's not just playing in the sports and industry.
It's actually way into the specialty that I happened to be uniquely good at and
passionate about.
So if you think about the fitness industry right now,
and this may be going on in many industries around the world,
we are moving fast from one size fits all to specialist categories.
This is really interesting.
Like back in the 90s if you think about retail used to go to the department
store and then we started going to boutique retail.
The same thing is happening in fitness.
So you see all these little boutiques popping up.
I'm sure some of you in the room are attending them,
whether it's cycling,
a little running boutiques,
bootcamp,
like Barry's bootcamp,
if anyone's attended that Zoomba from a dance standpoint,
Yoga,
all these little boutiques.
Now those feel very specialist.
But interestingly,
even within the cycling category,
you would think that in itself is a specialty.
But actually there's three different kinds of approach to cycling as a category.
So,
so if you look at the kinds of people that are attracted into the boutique
cycling world,
you have some that for whom it's a really social experience.
The number one reason they're coming is to be social and hang out with your
friends.
You have others,
like my friend in the middle of the room here who attends flywheel,
who probably were playing sports in high school,
they're probably a little bit competitive.
What I guess at that just a little bit.
Um,
and they come for performance because they're trying to push their athletic
performance to the next level.
And then lastly,
we have people for whom routine is what gets them in the door to a fitness I'm
offering because they don't love it.
It's not their lifestyle,
but they know they have to do it.
So they're just looking for what is the thing that is most convenient to where I
live.
Three different people with three completely different motivations around which
to build,
uh,
a cycling business.
So the notion here is to be spectacular for a few instead of being average for
many.
I love this chart.
You will all be able to find yourselves on this chart.
This is the u s population,
um,
and everybody's attitudes to physical activity and fitness.
So I will walk you through it.
To your right is 30% of the population simply inactive.
Totally don't work out at all.
They exist.
They're hard for me to understand,
but they exist.
Um,
then we have 18%,
which are what we call chore exercises for whom they really don't like fitness.
The doctor told them to do it,
like it's not fun at all,
but they do get out and push themselves.
Then you have hard workers,
physical laborers obviously.
And then we get into the more active.
So the social group I mentioned before,
for whom it's a really social activity that they want to get out there.
And then the routines as I mentioned,
and then these last two groups,
passionate exercises and competitive athletes.
Now,
competitive athletes,
15% of this population intellectually type as a competitive athlete,
that means you cannot let your kids when a monopoly,
that means wherever you are.
If you're on a treadmill next to someone,
you are aware of the numbers and you are trying to go faster than you cannot
help yourself.
That is what a competitive athlete is and flywheel has completely attracted that
one tiny segment because everything about our offering,
we have technology so you can track your performance,
compete with others in the room,
compete with yourself,
and that is where we focus all our energy.
We don't try and go after all of it.
We go after just one and I do believe as a business that makes us stronger and
certainly as a leader I'm like,
I'm with my people.
So I feel very comfortable intuitively with the decisions that I'm trying to
make.
Okay.
That was your specialist's games.
And now lastly,
I'm going to talk about breaking yourself to make yourself,
which is an important lesson that I learned,
particularly from the extreme as I interviewed that you can never get
complacent.
So forsee that means breaking yourself as a leader.
And I do believe having gone through the experience of being fired a couple of
times,
it really sucks when it's done to you.
It's a whole lot better to do it to yourself.
And that means really recognizing when are you in your comfort zone?
When have you been doing the same thing for awhile?
You've achieved mastery,
you feel amazing.
When is that time to push to a different place and get uncomfortable?
Now my case,
I actually quit my job a year ago to do just that because I was like,
I knew I wasn't personally growing.
It was the scariest thing I've ever done in my life,
but my God,
it's like I'd rather that than I didn't do it.
A few years went by and I suddenly wasn't keeping up and I got laid off again.
Right.
So what does that mean for you?
Where is that moment in your career where you have to really push outside and
it's involves challenging your most stubborn beliefs?
I really have found from a lot of the research I've done that we do tend to in
our minds get these kinds of beliefs early on in our career that we're not good
at certain things,
that we are either an analytical person or a creative person or whatever the
category might be.
And we tend to often like those become our blind spots and we just don't kind of
want to deal with them.
But actually you should deal with them and it's okay.
That's breaking yourself down to make yourself like what is it that you are sort
of avoiding and your job.
It isn't an area of decision making strength for you.
Can you go and take an out of work class on it to really push yourself to the
next level?
Because that is the kind of thing it will feel uncomfortable but it will
certainly get you there
and then break yourself as a business.
So you've got to think as a leader,
it is your responsibility to constantly get outside your comfort zone and learn
new things.
But you also have to think as a business,
what does that mean organizationally,
I had the great experience of working at Nike and then I'm leaving at around the
time when the whole company was reorientating itself in terms of how they work
together,
going from footwear apparel and equipment,
two categories,
sucker running,
et cetera.
And what that caused was all of the employees to move into a different place of
how they were interacting with different people to innovate,
which was actually incredibly uncomfortable,
but obviously leads to new thinking and new innovation.
So what does that mean for your teams?
Can you get them into different train tracks in order to create new innovation
and inspiration?
It's so important,
I believe,
to look outside your category,
to get inspiration for what you may do going forward.
If I think about Strava,
like if we would just to stay in category,
we'd be looking at Linkedin,
at Facebook,
at all of the obvious social networking players and say,
well,
let's do the same thing as them.
But guess what?
Strivr is probably possibly one of the only silicon valley brands that people
tattoo on their ankles because they are so passionate about it.
So we need to look at the likes of Harley Davidson for inspiration.
Not those other brands or in terms of an ad marketplace,
were more relevant to look at the local cycling shop and how they are curating
products for their passionate riders.
The necessary a regular online ad marketplace.
So thinking about breaking yourself down and getting inspiration from other
places.
And then lastly,
apologies of putting that Disney song into your heads.
It's going to stay there.
Now,
um,
let it go.
And what I mean by this is breaking yourself down by definition means letting go
of things that I comfortable to you and it's not going to feel good.
But what happens on the other side is always profound amounts of growth.
I think about whether that means relocating to a different city because you got
a job opportunity.
Whether it means moving into a different department that you're uncomfortable
with,
always you have to let go of something that was comfortable to get there.
But always once you're through it,
it's incredibly empowering in terms of how you grow.
And I would say from all of the people I interviewed for my book,
this was the one thing that really blew me away the most was that these were
like massively accomplished people at the top of their game yet.
So willing to be humble and take a step back and say,
I'm going to start over and something because I want to learn more,
which is a hard thing to do when you're already at the top of your game.
So it is about letting go.
And that's my three lessons for the day.
So making failure,
your fuel,
knowing what your specialist's Gamers,
and then lastly,
break yourself to make yourself,
to really push yourself to the next level.
And so with that,
I think we have time for questions,
I believe.
Well don't be shy.
Hi there.
So you started the,
the talk about how New Zealand,
there's a big focus on exercise and outdoor activities.
So do you think that maybe what didn't go well at Atari and some of the others
where that even just the content of the job,
like you had to work at a company where you had core values or passions?
Definitely,
yeah,
I think passions,
um,
and understanding because you are 100% right,
like I can still remember being in this office in Santa Monica with this,
is that Atari with a ton of,
um,
the programming guys who would literally,
they had zero interest in going outside into any part of the universe other than
working together.
And I found,
I was just like,
how is that possible?
It's sunny outside.
We should all be going for a run.
You know,
it's like it just was a total disconnect and I don't like,
I don't judge that group of people,
that's their lifestyle,
but I don't understand it.
I didn't have a connection to it.
So I think it's important to not only have a passion for it,
but when you do,
you have a lot more,
um,
just sheer confidence to make decisions and take risks.
So in the case of video games,
you know,
you're faced with,
should I do this or should I do that in picking which title we're going to get
behind for the Christmas season?
I don't know because I'm not that player yet.
When I'm in suddenly Nike,
it's like asking me questions about how an athlete's going to respond to
something.
I'm like,
I got this because I lived it.
I know it.
So I do think it is about the content but also your own just drive and passion
to get behind it
for sure.
Well thank you very much for your talk.
Um,
I love the point about really knowing what you're great at and like focusing and
doubling down on that.
And I'm wondering if you could talk a little bit more about,
do you think about that as like a functional expertise and industry expertise
type of organization to be a part of?
Because I think what's interesting is you did many different things to different
places.
So kind of what's the common thread between,
um,
you know,
knowing,
knowing what you're really good at and what's the common thread between
airlines,
music,
video games and sports.
You know,
cause I think that is a great question.
And um,
one of the things that I write about in the book is that I believe that the
system is designed to make you fit in.
I think for most of us,
whether it's in high school,
you know,
how we all Kinda got labeled as you're either super smart or a jock or you know,
and likewise you get your first job.
And I do think your first job,
like recruiters are typically going to want to keep you in the same place.
Like I remember being,
I was in the airlines for six years and all I wanted to do was work for Nike.
Like in my head,
I'm a marketing person at an a brand,
doesn't matter what category there's,
but the recruiters were like,
you're an airline person.
And I'm like,
do I look like I sniffed jet fuel?
Like,
no,
I'm not.
I mean,
you don't know what I mean.
And,
and so I do believe that you are the only one that can navigate yourself out of
those verticals that people will put you into and you have to do it.
And then the question is,
you ask as an industry or functional,
I actually think it's a process of self discovery to figure out what it is for
you.
It might be that you're just bang on in the right industry and that's exactly
where you should be.
Or as I found that you were,
a lot of the people I interviewed,
many of them didn't figure out where their place was to sort of land until well
into their thirties.
And even though you might go,
well,
did that mean the first 10 years was wasted?
No.
Like in every instance it was kind of taking an expertise from here and
connecting over here.
Great example is one of my favorite stories in the book was a woman who,
um,
had done to her MBA.
She was consulting,
um,
and in the music industry.
And so she was doing marketing represented Gwen Steffani like at the top of the
game,
right?
Yeah.
Deep down inside she was a singer and she's like,
I'm really low,
like miserable because I'm marketing leads other people and I'm not,
you know,
going back to what I did as a child has,
she goes and basically long story short studies,
they're singing again and ends up coming back and ends up singing at the Oscars
when Slumdog millionaire was,
um,
nominators a great story,
which leads her into,
okay,
now I'm going to be a full time artist.
And who would have thought all that business experience enabled her to create,
she's now created our brand,
her and you know,
so does come together.
And I think it's just about having the willingness to pursue new experiences.
Even if it means it feels like you're starting over because you're not,
you're going to be adding it to what you already had.
Definitely.
Thank you so much.
Um,
two questions.
One,
I'm curious what your sport was or,
or is insufficient to,
uh,
to spinning.
And then second,
I thought the breakdown of competitive social and convenience was really
interested in and from the perspective of flywheel competitive definitely makes
sense with this spinning part of it.
How does bar fit into that?
Because if you're going for a special,
a specialization of competition,
that to me,
doesn't it?
Yeah,
there's very different for sure.
So,
um,
I would say,
so we at Flywheel we have the secondary offering called fly by,
which is,
um,
a bar workout for anyone who knows what that is,
where and it is,
it's,
it doesn't feel like it's the right compliment because it feels like it would be
a different type of consumer.
But it is precision training.
And what we find is the people who are doing a flywheel that's doing a lot of
cardio for them,
but they also need to complement that.
And our bar program,
it's not the easiest one in the market by any stretch.
And so I think it really appeals to that person who's like,
okay,
I'm in,
I'm going to go and really feel it today.
You know?
So it does,
uh,
it does actually end up connecting because of the type of programming that it
is.
And then to answer your question,
tried field hockey,
failed,
try tennis,
failed skiing,
failed waterskiing,
fouled sailing,
all of the above.
But now I do a lot of fly wheel obviously and running and I do um,
tough mudders.
Anyone in this room done tough mudder.
One of the great stories in the book by the way,
is will the founder of tough mudder,
because that's a great example.
You'll question of,
you know,
his parents are like,
oh,
you just go be a consultant.
And he's like,
no,
I want to electrocute people for fun.
You know,
it's like,
it didn't sound like it was going to be a huge success and it's now something
I've believed they had something like 3 million people have taken these things
globally.
I mean it's off the charts success story,
but a great example of he had taken all these weird experiences.
He worked in the counter terrorism unit,
he went to Harvard business going like all these crazy things to create this
what like sort of unheard of concept.
So
for sure.
Hi.
Um,
so one thing that I really like about firewall and I think a lot of other people
do is like how it's like kind of on the forefront of workout technology and like
how you can learn so much more about yourself.
So my question for you is kind of like what technology is coming next for
flywheel and like where are you guys going to take it in and say five years?
Oh,
it's coming.
So yeah,
it's a great question because um,
flywheel actually pioneered the technology on the bikes.
So for anyone who has been in the world of fitness for years,
spinning was created in the 90s,
like spinning I endo cycling.
But for many years you could be that person in the back of a dark room when they
said to not resistance and you're sort of kind of pretending and not really.
Um,
and what flywheel did was add technology to the bike so that when you are
riding,
the instructor would say,
I want your resistance to be here and I want you to be hitting this on the Rpms,
which is holding you very,
very accountable as you know.
And what's neat about that I think is that people can then hold themselves
accountable over a long period of time to how they're doing.
Um,
so now I do believe and just,
you know,
with the team that we are working with at fly where we all believe that the
future of fitness is accountability.
I think we're gonna see this more and more and more across every category where
people,
they want to know the output of that particular piece of effort compared to
anything else that they were doing.
It's not a perfect science yet because we can't track things like bar and the
same way that we can,
um,
uh,
cycling workout.
But I believe that's where all of our effort needs to go.
I also believe that,
um,
uh,
fit the fitness industry.
And as you guys know,
we have the quantified self.
We got a little too carried away with tracking the data as opposed to giving
insights off the data.
Like,
you know,
going from sort of numbers to knowledge if you will.
And I do think that's also where the future is.
Like how do we use that data to prod you to push you to get you to go to the
next level.
So we definitely have a lot of things coming as a big announcement actually
coming in three weeks.
So watch the space.
But very much we believe that technology and accountability is at the core of
willfulness has going for sure.
Okay.
So,
uh,
so I love your message of extreme mastery and focus.
Um,
I was also interested though when you talked about challenging yourself and if
you're a creative person and try to be more analytical.
So how do you balance the two and how do you decide one,
do you just focus on mastery verse challenging yourself to something get up?
So I'll give you a personal example and cause I think all of us,
when we play to our extreme strengths,
you just like,
you go to a different level of performance.
And for me,
innovation,
creativity,
all these things have always been like that I can do easily.
Then I find myself president of a $5 billion business that's needing to be
turned around.
And by the way,
when I was 20,
I failed stage one accounting.
And so in my head had my entire career told myself,
I suck,
I suck.
I can't do this,
avoided it to,
you know,
and finally I was in a job where you can,
you can't hide anymore.
And so I actually like eventually put my hand up to my boss and I said,
this is an issue.
I ended up going down the street actually to have it remedial finance.
Um,
which was awesome for so many reasons.
But here's the thing,
it will,
I will never be like a CFO.
But what I did come back with was actually a real passion for,
I really enjoyed it and loved it.
And it,
it is just a compliment so that I have a better view that I can balance my
strengths with.
So that's one example where I think you need to make sure you're not just
ignoring the blind spots.
That said,
I also know I will never in any role not surround myself with really amazing CFO
because that's not ever going to be my biggest strength.
So it's about knowing kind of how to surround yourself with the opposite skills
as well as kind of just shoring up your knowledge to make sure it's not a blind
spot is what I would say.
I have so much for coming.
Um,
so a lot of us work at,
well a very large company or work with very large companies where,
um,
you know,
the break yourself to make yourself is,
is more challenging,
you know?
And so when you're working in one of those larger cultures that has a lot of
inertia to not change or not break there Yellen organization,
what advice do you have for,
you know,
staying true to your own individual.
Then also impacting a potential break in that own organization and leading that
herself?
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
what am I,
the,
my favorite chapters in the book actually is,
um,
what I call change the game.
And it's my personal experience of actually being at Gatorade,
which Pepsi Co you may work with,
some of you is a giant company within which,
you know,
Gatorade was one,
$5 billion piece and it required,
I mean,
this was a business that and after the recession,
you know,
was a $5 billion top line that lost 500 million off the top line in one year.
I mean,
it was huge,
right?
And so small incremental change clearly wasn't going to do it yet,
uh,
to move everyone along,
like everything that we were needing to do to fix the business week,
totally counter to what had worked for a really long time.
And so you sort of,
I remember along the way having an eye,
there's a lot of dramatic moments in the story where,
you know,
we,
we thought we were heading the right direction and the business didn't start
turning.
And everyone's like questioning,
have I totally screwed up the business here?
All of the above.
But I do believe,
like in that case,
I,
two things going from a one was that by now I had developed this real specialty
of understanding athletes,
innovation in that space.
And I knew it better than anyone in terms of the broader peer group because it
was where I'd grown up.
And secondly,
I'd been fired twice in my twenties so every step of the way,
I remember saying to myself to the point of inertia,
if I play on the defense,
we're not going to win and I am going to get fired.
If I play on the offense,
there's a good chance we'll win.
And there's also a decent chance I'll get fired.
But that's okay.
Cause I've been there before and I'd rather go down trying to do what I did know
how to do best.
And I do believe for all of us,
like we get into these situations,
particularly in big companies and particularly in times like the recession where
the fear kicks in and no one if everyone's like,
but the boss said they wanted Blah Blah and this is what I've been told to do.
But the the boss doesn't want you to please and they want you to drive results.
And I think as long as you can frame what you're doing around,
I know this doesn't feel right,
but here's the line from a to B and stay with it and like go with all your
specialty skills.
That's the other thing I really believe in.
Like you will have so much more conviction if you come from a place that's your
own personal expertise and you kind of have no choice but to go against the
inertia because in the end what happens if you don't?
So I love that question by the way.
Thank you.
One more question if no one else is in line.
When it comes
to the space that you're in,
sort of fitness,
sports in general,
is there a trend that you of see coming up behind you that you're like,
Huh,
that's sort of interesting.
I wonder where that goes,
whether it's in the breakdown of the three different kinds of spaces or,
and your kind of fitness or sort of what's,
what are you seeing out of the corner of your eye?
That's a great question.
I definitely believe that the boutique specializing phenomenon is at the very
beginning of where it's going.
Um,
boutique fitness has grown 400% in the last four years and big box gyms have
stayed flat.
So,
and what's interesting is that people are coming in to the boutique category.
Some of it's a little bit of,
it is coming from big,
um,
full service gyms.
A lot of it's people coming in to fitness for the first time.
It's creating a lot of energy in the category.
I mean,
health and wellness is in a great place,
right?
Um,
but I believe with boutique we're still at the very beginning because it's,
um,
nobody's really blown up and scaled yet.
The way,
if you go back to retail in the 90s,
like some of those boutique brands really took it to the next level.
And I believe what I'm seeing at least is there's a lot of people coming into
the fitness space right now,
whether it's sophisticated investors,
leaders,
whatever.
I believe it's all going to start going upwards and scaling in a big way.
I also think that technology is going to be a huge driver and Omni channel
experiences.
I think that's going to be so that you can be a part of the flywheel community
and you can participate in it and it wherever you may be around the world.
Um,
I think that's a big piece of where we're going.
That said,
I do think that the,
um,
in person experience is not going away.
And what I mean by that is if you look across retail right now,
definitely retail in general is suffering because everything's moving to
ecommerce.
But look at what's booming.
It's things like theme,
parks,
restaurants,
fitness.
Because I believe humans are craving time with other humans and that's what
those kind of businesses are bringing his experiences together.
So I think that's not going to go away.
In fact,
I think there's a lot more opportunity right there.
Who were your favorite two subjects that you interviewed for the book and for
any kind of quirky different reason than people might know?
Yes.
So funny.
I can't,
it's like picking one of my children.
Um,
no I did.
So the,
it's a,
it's,
I will say,
I'll pick two interesting subjects.
Firstly,
I will start by saying there's an amazing Gugler on the book.
Um,
Dan Keisling if anyone knows who now works in Jigsaw.
So he's a fan favorite,
you can find him.
Um,
but I would say probably the unexpected ones that really blew me away were,
um,
Mr Cartoon,
the Tattoo artist was just phenomenal in terms of where he came from,
where he got to,
how he just had this incredible ability to get uncomfortable and keep learning.
I mean,
he and some of his one liners,
which is awesome.
I really,
really him.
Um,
and then there's a personal story actually connection to me,
my sister in law.
And it's an incredible story of overcoming profound mental health issues to
become really quite successful on the global stage.
And so different than anything else in the book but so incredibly inspiring.
But there's,
they're all amazing.
They were great stories.
Definitely.
How do you think about the competition?
Like let's use cell cycle obviously there according to your categories,
they're in maybe a different one,
but how much do you as the CEO pay attention to them and without getting too
paranoid are too distracted but still making sure that you know what you're up
against if they're your top competitor.
Yeah.
Well first of all I'm going to say something,
it would probably sound surprising,
but I love soul cycle and I really,
I believe that when they do well,
the category does well.
We all do well.
Same with Palestine.
Like I think I actually believe all of us are bringing tons of energy and all
the boats are rising.
So I think,
and what's really interesting is they are very different consumers,
people coming for very different reasons.
So I don't spend a lot of time thinking about them because I do spend a lot of
time thinking about our core consumer who's looking for something quite
different.
And I would say I personally learned a lot from working at a company like virgin
or Nike where they never thought about the competition and only play their own
game compared to the soda wars,
you know,
coke and Pepsi,
Powerade,
Gatorade,
we,
it's a completely different mindset and that can drag you into different places
that aren't necessarily right for your consumer.
So I think I came away with that going stay focused.
Definitely.
So thank you so much for coming.
I'm a flywheel Devo tea,
so I'm so excited to see you here.
And for those who haven't tried it,
we have a great Gugler discounts.
Oh yes.
Um,
in the vein of,
I know you had mentioned that boutique fitness is sort of just starting and it's
going to explode.
What do you foresee as one of the biggest challenges facing flywheel in the
coming years?
I would say staying focused actually,
because I do think that there is a ton of excitement around the fitness category
in general.
I also think daily there's new technology and innovation that people knocking
down our door wanting to suggest we do this,
that and the other and it's,
I personally hit find because I have not grown up in a technology company like
you or as a CEO,
it's hard to sort the real ideas from the many things that are just going to
fall by the wayside,
you know,
and,
and not get distracted by the wrong one.
So I actually think the opportunity is so right for us,
but we have to know we've got a place the right bets and focus on them and not
get too spread too thin,
I don't think.
Thanks.
With your focus and leadership on technology and accountability in the fitness
space,
are you all thinking about integrating fitness data with larger healthcare data
and how does that materialize?
Yes.
Uh,
we are at the very beginning of,
began to think about it because we're still a very young company.
But for sure I think that's what we all need to do.
That's what our consumers want us to do is help them get a more holistic
picture.
So absolutely,
definitely.
Hi.
Um,
you mentioned a lot about like failing early and failing fast.
One,
it was wondering if you could talk a little bit about also like,
um,
during the times when you have failed,
like how did you go about picking yourself back up?
Yeah.
What are different support networks?
We had to allow that introspection and get yourself to be propelled up for that
posts.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
So let's talk about failing fast for a section for,
for second and failing hard.
Maybe I'll use that term because I fail fast is a like big idea that thankfully
the,
you guys have bought to the world in general in terms of as we are in business
and thinking about innovation,
trying,
experimenting,
iterating,
rolling,
moving.
And we all have to be better at doing that.
That is different to failure.
That really deeply impacts you.
And teaches you and actually takes you personally to another level.
And that is one of the reasons I went to great lengths to just put it all out
there.
And by the way,
I'm not the only one,
like some of the other stories in my book,
I said to everyone,
I,
when I interviewed them,
I don't want the great surface amazingness.
I want tell me how it felt.
And like Condoleezza Rice making the decision,
extraordinarily tough decision to give up on her dream of being a concert
pianist and take it,
you know,
tell me what that feels like.
Um,
but what I would say is you have to like,
I actually breakdown in the book the real process of how you should go through
it cause everyone says to be,
how do you go into an interview after you've just been fired twice.
Just a good Christian,
but you have to,
I believe really feel it and process it.
And if you've ever had a failure,
I know in my case I spent the first at least month telling everyone around me
that it was their fault.
Like,
you know,
must've been the sucky industry,
the leadership,
whatever.
And everyone you tell that to,
you can sort of see in their eyes they don't really believe you.
And that's because you don't really believe you.
And then you have to just sit there and go,
okay,
this hurts.
I'm going to own it.
But the minute you actually take ownership for it and man up and say it to
someone,
like in a job interview saying,
I got fired because I did this,
which means I will never make that mistake again.
It's so empowering because you own it,
you're in control of it from then on.
So I do think we all tend to,
it's human nature to want to cover up fails because you kind of think it to bad
thing,
but when you do,
it's like this scary thing that's always chasing you through life and,
and maybe it's going to catch up and someone's going to find out about it one
day.
It's better just to feel it,
own it.
And then by the way,
you do get great growth and that's what you did it for.
Right.
I always tell people,
don't fail if you're not going to get the output on the other side.
For sure.
I think my little counter clock is about to run out,
so thank you very much.
It's been really fun.
Great.
Kristen
[inaudible].